que remarquer fonds en premier chez un
homme d'abord son allure générale
ensuite on décompose en jeu risque de
effectivement remarqué ses mains qui
sont très importantes surtout au niveau
du toucher de la caresse ses yeux enfin
sa beauté quand même c'est très
important
autre chose le postérieur aussi bien
fait bien monté et bon la braguette je
veux dire l'ensemble d'un homme ce qui
ce qui ressemble à un homme
ce qui est important mais à moi je
remarque que les fesses la démarche et
les yeux tellement le regard plus les
les yeux puis après le regard les yeux
et les mains parce que
par les mains on donne en prendre
pour marquer la délicatesse d'un homme
dans sa violence importe où vous auriez
vous des hommes entre femmes ça dépend
avec mes amis les plus proches en parle
assez crûment
nous sommes assez cru je pense que là
dessus on va se retourner le compliment
la politesse je peux vous donner un
exemple très bref cet ami qui ayant une
nuit assez sympa me dit le lendemain
elle se contente de me dire vous voyez
vous si il m'est arrivé de parler des
hommes ça serait plutôt avec des hommes
et disons que ce que j'ai pu apprendre
pour pour faire la conquête d'un
bonhomme ou du clair c'était surtout
avec un homosexuel
disons que mon plus grand professeur
d'amour ça a été un homosexuel
lui m'a pris parce qu'ils savaient bien
son corps à lui et comment on pouvait le
toucher
comment il fallait faire en fait ce
qu'une femme ne peut pas savoir
il vous a appris à caresser oui sûrement
il m'a appris
bon ce qui pouvait toucher un bonhomme
parce que parce qu'il est homme et qui
connaît mieux son corps que moi je
connais bien de la même façon d'ailleurs
je pense qu'une femme caresse infiniment
mieux une femme qu'un homme quel conseil
s'était donné quelques conseils va-t-il
deux des têtes - légère peut-être que je
ne l'étais disons d'appuyer plus + wii
de caresser plus fort que en fait je
leur ai fait de moi même et dans we
pensons qu'en fait la légèreté des
carrés c'était était bleu mieux venu que
puis devant d'autres choses mais c'est
quoi d'autre c'est difficile
sachez-le peut-être de prendre des
initiatives
étonnante disons que l'étonnement là
dedans où l'inattendu dans une relation
de corps à corps peut troubler et oui
les plus excités que de toute façon
demander quelque chose ça démoli la
moitié du plaisir
comment imaginez-vous une pornographie
destiné aux femmes ça c'est assez
compliqué pour l'homme c'est très facile
parce que bon il ya les films x
ces films qui sont bons beaucoup plus
destiné aux hommes justement parce
qu'ils sont ils ont ce côté très très
visuel il aime mater que nous les femmes
bon même si on a envie on se met à
gagner beaucoup plus
ceci dit concevoir une pornographie
féminine ne sais pas c'est difficile
à mon avis ça peut exister je suis sûr
que ça se vendrait que ça marcherait
mais je crois que les vêtements surtout
bon si un homme se déshabille devant moi
je veux bien ça peut être très excitant
si le fait bien s'il est beau si la
musique est bien aussi l'éclairage et où
enfin ça peut être un beau spectacle et
tout mais c'est après qui me fait peur
moi c'est qu'ils s'en aillent bon ça y
est j'ai terminé ma soirée de charme
tout le monde mais c'est fini et ça moi
je voudrais bien dans mon lit après ça
me donnera envie de l'avoir dans mon lit
s'il est là devant moi se déshabiller à
s'exhiber tout est
ça je trouve c'est ça surtout que je
redouterais mois mais le but de la
pornographie s'était désisté voilà imad
d'avoir un final c'est pour ça que la
pornographie et personnellement j'en
vois pas trop le besoin pour moi je dis
une pornographie destiné aux femmes je
crois qu'elle doit surtout pas être la
même que celle destinée aux hommes
surtout elle doit être précise pas du
tout par photo et mais plutôt par parole
ou sais pas peut-être par kas est
justement enfin qu'il ferait appel à
l'oreille on entendrait que la voix ou
bien
je pense que tout ce qui est destiné à
la femme doit jouer plus sur
l'imaginaire que sur la précision pour
que la femme puisse mieux s'identifier à
la femme qu'elle verrait ou bien pour
quelles qu'elles soient moins blessés ou
choqués par des images précises
avez-vous des ventes hausse moi j'ai un
fantasme de domination
simon a bien dominé un homme
complètement dans la vie ça m'intéresse
pas vraiment mais dans un lieu oui parce
que je crois qu'un fantasme c'est en
fait c'est toujours sexuelle donc le
côté dans la vie c'est plus facile à
réaliser a en manoeuvrant bien on peut
arriver à dominer un homme dans un lycée
comme c'est moins évident parce qu'ils
sont pas tellement habitués et c'est sur
son compte youtube ils ont un peu
l'impression qu'on touche à l'art sacré
virilité mais je trouve que c'est plus
agréable pour une fade de dominer dans
un livre c'est à dire de faire ce
qu'elle veut du début à la fin de
décider elle le moment ça se fera ou ce
qu'il faudra faire c'était quelqu'un
d'assez pour toi ah non pas du tout
jamais jamais jamais géré
non voilà moi c'est tout simple et moi
mon autre fantasme physx et les requins
1,5 concerne la population française
allez-vous du chanteur le fantasme de
viol
des centaines de groupes on s'entasse
nous je peux plus souvent le fantasme de
croûte
notamment dans des périodes de
frustration pour durer assez longtemps
trois mois sans aucune relation sexuelle
donc
désir
très grand désir charnel
[Musique]
qui ne sera apportée justement par
plusieurs hommes
d'imagination de bitter partie penneteau
seul avec plusieurs hommes est seul avec
quoi sert hazard nous
comment expliquez vous ce matin je pense
que c'est du un sentiment de rejet
vis-à-vis de mon père d'un jeune
ça m'a donné envie d'être au premier
plan donc
dans une relation sexuelle et d'avoir
les hommes à musique romantique
j'ai un fantasme que mon avis beaucoup
de femmes mais aussi c'est un fantasme
de femmes d'amour physique avec des
femmes
je crois que
ça c'est assez important aussi je crois
que c'est une expérience importante
c'est différent avec les hommes ça rien
à voir y at il des fantasmes connais
beaucoup de femmes
moi je crois d'après ce que j'ai entendu
1 2
copine à moi qui m'ont souvent dit que
soit sa langue est arrivé soit elle
aimerait bien remettre un homosexuel
dans le droit chemin
c'est à dire coucher avec un homosexuel
arrivé à qui la désirent le faire bander
quoi et tu crois qu'il ya un autre
fantasme ou six qui est important c'est
le fantasme d'être à la fois en tailleur
chanel et puis en dessous en guêpière
noir comme une pluie de l'armée s'est
réuni non aurez-vous je crois que je
serai dans les roches vraiment je suis
bien j'allais à cabourg une fois avec
une voiture décapotable et à la sortie
d'une ville c'était la nuit à la sortie
d'une ville donc dans les dernières
lumières
j'ai vu sur le bord de la route un
ravissant jeune homme en train de faire
du stop et je les fais monter et puis
bon on est resté silencieux quelques
kilomètres et après j'ai commencé à lui
parler et quand il a ouvert la bouche
je me suis arrêté je les fais descendre
c'est vous dire que en fait même le plus
beau musée du monde ne me troublerait
pas du tout et que pour moi les mots ont
une importance énorme dans toute
relation et pour créer chez moi le
trouble où le désir ou où l'excitation
c'est sûr qu'il va y avoir des mots et
pas n'importe quel mot et en plus de ça
je suis tellement troublés par les mots
et je reçois si peu ce que j'attends que
j'en suis venu à m'écrire des lettre que
j'envoie dans des postes restants dans
des pays très lointain en mettant au dos
de la lettre évidemment mon nom et mon
adresse
et puis un mois et demi plus tard je
reçois donc ces lettres que je me suis
écrite et que je lis avec bonheur je me
parle je me dis en fait je me donne ce
que je voudrais entendre
ondine mafall chérie ma lointaine
doucement aimé mon amour si tu n'aimais
pas autant ce pays de mer et de rêve
je crois que je ne t'aurais pas laisser
partir tu ne ronronne plus ni de
bataille à mon oreille
la maison est restée vide et tu me
manques je t'imagine seul au milieu des
vagues qui écume et roule et tu te
rendes aux sables rouler moulu heureuse
comme si toute la nuit je t'avais fait
l'amour qu'elle fantasme vous accueille
moi j'aime beaucoup le vers la liberté
la campagne les champs à tout ce qui est
l'immensité vraiment être être un avec
la nature c'est très très bien surtout
avec avec un homme je pense que c'est ça
apporte beaucoup
qu'est-ce qui vous ont pu jeter sous
vire souffrant d'asthme
les obligations quotidiennes peut être
manque de temps jean notre centaine ici
diversité des lieux fantasmes des lieux
notamment j'aimerais bien faire l'amour
par exemple dans une piscine d'une
église terrains de tennis a mac
moi j'aimerais tellement être esclave et
obéir et qu'on me dise fait ceci est
fait cela parce que finalement la
liberté c'est de pas avoir de
responsabilités auriez vous un fantasme
de soumission peut-être peut-être bien
que j'aie un fantasme soumission en tout
cas j'aimerais bien qu'au lieu de dire
mettrait ses amants ont dix mètres et
amante
est ce que vous croyez qu'à la suite de
l'émission des hommes vont écrire qui
diront j'aimerais être tôt m comme
beaucoup le savent il y a déjà beaucoup
de femmes
on aime bien par exemple violent ça
c'est malheureusement c'est pour ça que
parfois il est très difficile de savoir
si c'est vraiment un malencontreux
il y à aussi bon la secrétaire sur les
joues ton directeur ça c'est une chose
qui est très classique aussi ses breaks
beaucoup de mal à fantasmes poser avec
leur patron bon
ben hilli à la balade la rencontre de
l'inconnu l'imprévu 3 ou 4 ou un seul
jeu dire ça dépend de l'appétit et oui
mais ça c'est les fantasmes je veux dire
la femme est quand même assez maso lmh
bien elle aime bien se prendre une bonne
trempe de temps en temps peut-être est
fantasque j'ai eu un fantasme de viol
mais je crois que beaucoup de femmes ou
ce fantasme ah oui j'avais envie j'avais
envie ou j'espérais que voilà on
entraînerait au fond d'un bois et que et
que je serai violée peut-être parce que
c'est l inattendu qui me plaisait et
qu'est-ce qui serait attirons dans le
viol
l'inconnue peut-être désir de faire
l'amour avec un inconnu sans aucune
relation
psychologique avec lettres se libérer
plus facilement quand on connaît pas
mais c'est aussi peut-être une partie
viol c'est pas tellement un désir le
font pas ce serait plutôt une peur
pour ça que ce serait comment justement
à beaucoup de femmes dans les deux cas
aussi bien le viol que le la rencontre
avec l'inconnu il s'agit d'abord
peut-être d'agro narcissisme de la femme
qui ne veut considérer que son propre
corps et que l'homme par rapport
seulement aux caresses kg brutalité qui
fait sur le
qu'il fait sur le corps de la femme et
puis peut-être que dans le fantasme a
connu il ya peut-être une grande peur de
l'amour aussi tout simplement vous aimez
ont senti la découpe de los santos
oui mais qui sont à l'écouté il ya
toujours une une peur de se qualifier là
dessus toujours la peur d'être traitée
de [ __ ] ou enfin sont tellement pris
dans des principes est une femme qui on
parle si ouvertement
parce qu'on prend ça nous est arrivé oui
une fois
traitée de [ __ ] oui
quelqu'un qui était dans mes principes
très bourgeois n'est ce pas tellement
fait un peu vieille france
moralité la part
frappée d'interdît aussi il y en a
beaucoup qui sont pensés encore le nom
savent pas vivre leur sexualité
[Musique]